في تطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا هذا
موقع ريبال العسكريه المختصر بان الجيش
الروسي فجر ليله الماضيه جستري انطوانوف
وكخوفك على نهر دنبرو في خلصن بعد ما اكمل
سحب جميع قوته من الضفه اليمنى للنهار
المد
فعيه
عبور القوات المتبقيه الى الضفه اليسرى
لتزامني مع ابطائي تقدم القوات الاخرانيه
باتجاه مدينتي
خوفك على نهر والذي يضم محطه توليد الطاقه
الكهربائيه تضررت في قصف القوات
الاوكرانيه على القوات الروسيه كانت تعبنا
النهر
وكانت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه قد اعلنت ان
انفجارات عنيفه دوت في محيط الجسري
انتنوفو محطه كخوفك لانتاج الطاقه
الكهرومائيه في الضفه الغربيه من نهر
النيبرو بخرسون
روسيه رسميه صورا قالت انها للحظه اطلاق
الصواريخ وانفجارها في محيط جسر انطونوف
الذي يربط بين ضفتيه نهر
النيل اندلع في محيط المدينه